all right
here we are
first time i do this i need to
turn this time i do this
all right we'll eliminate the echo here
all right and so i have a tablet next to
me also so i'll be able to see the chat
so hopefully my
massive disability technology won't be
won't be a hindrance so let's see how
this goes
so one of the things that um
last week we reached 100 000 subscribers
on the youtube channel and so
i asked a bunch of people on social
media what they would like
one of the the biggest answer was to
have my brother back on the channel
which i would absolutely love but uh i
don't think i don't think it's gonna
happen
the other thing that came on a lot was a
commentary
on revelation which i am starting i've
done already done one video
we'll do another video and then possibly
a third video not sure yet
and yet another thing that appeared was
people saying they wanted to see a live
uh carving and so i thought okay sure i
could do that that's fine
so i've got a small carving that i need
to do
and so um and so let's do it i don't
know if i'll be able to finish the whole
thing while i'm doing the live stream
but who knows we'll see we'll see how it
goes and so the small carving is a small
carving of the mother of god
and i'm doing it on a piece of steel
tight a piece of soapstone you can see
here
um and so what how i do it is this is a
drawing that i did of
of the mother god that i use for this
particular pattern
and i just used a piece of carbon paper
underneath because i need to trace
the drawing on the stone
so i'm really starting guys from the
beginning i guess i could have started
after i
i could have started after making the
drawing but
i was all excited about doing this
because i had never done it before
so i'm gonna try to take a look at the
chat once in a while
there are no moderators as i know of
unless someone
unless like brad or lisa decide to hop
in
uh when they noticed this i didn't warn
them that i was doing this
so there are no moderators so it's
possible that things will get a little
loopy in the uh comment section
in the chat sorry if that happens just
ignore the ignore the trolls
so
so one of the really interesting things
that happened last week
i was kind of absent from social media i
was supposed to go
i was supposed to go to saskatoon to
teach a carving class
and uh because of kovid
it was just complicated it was like
semi-legal for me to stay with them and
everything everything was
suspicious so i decided not to go and
there are other reasons too like
uh just at home it was just better that
i stay home and so
and so they asked me if i could maybe
carve
make a carving training record it and uh
send them the videos
and so i thought okay yeah i could do
that that's not a problem and i kind of
know how fast i carve things so i
thought it could work
and um and so i grossly
misinter like i grossly mistook how much
time
it was going to take me it took me like
five times more
than what i what i had planned on
because of the editing because
i kept i kept uh i kept having some
technical problems with the camera and
stuff
and lighting and all the uh so many
problems anyways
so i barely slept last week because i do
have spent all night editing these
videos for carving and stuff
so what i want when i'm doing this
tracing is i really just want the basic
lines for myself
if i was if i was teaching a class i
would tell you to trace all the lines
because
it's good to get to know get to know the
image
but you know i i really i know this
image so well
because i've carved it so many times so
that's all i'm going to put on there
so jonathan henry asked how did you come
up with the design for the drawing
and if you made it up from scratch how
do you decide with symbolism to add
style to use
so the drawing is based on a traditional
image it's a it's an image of them of
the mother of god supplicant
it would be it would be an image that
would be next to
christ and so you can imagine her head
she's bowing
and next to it here would be an image of
christ and on the other side would be an
image of saint john the baptist which is
called the deissus so three images
together
and uh and so usually you see the whole
image oh actually
i can show you because
this was the this is the carving i was
working on for the training last week
and so you can see this is a full image
of
the the type of image that would be in
this deuces
so you can see saint john the baptist
with his arms out showing us
christ who would be in the middle and
the mother of god
on the other side but now it's just the
face of the mother of god
so the idea is i base my i base my
drawing on on a traditional pattern
but obviously there is some there is
some leeway to adjust it to what you
want you know to emphasize different
things
and to uh especially if i'm carving
so if i'm carving i need to uh
i need to adjust the uh oh i need to
move this a little bit here
it's gonna be a little sketchy at the
beginning because i i've never done this
before
all right
so in a carving there are certain things
in a carving that are difficult to do
that are not the same as a painting like
there are some things in painting that
you can't do
in carving so you need to make sure that
your design is appropriate for
carving but this image is really just a
basic image of
of the mother god which would be
recognized by any chris or orthodox
christian
that goes to church because it's the
type of image which
would be which would also be uh in a
in the diocese on on the um
on the iconostasis if someone has a big
iconostasis
this this type of limit would be on the
iconostasis
so someone asked if i'm still taking
commissions and the answer is
i am not taking commissions at this time
uh
my right now my my waiting list is like
two years
and and uh
you know it got really bad because of
the flooding in my house because i was
out of the workshop it was just hard to
to to stay focused on on the carving
like i was still carving but it was just
really difficult to get a nice workflow
um but now from since but during the
time of the flood i hired
an assistant who's helping me
um and so i'm hoping that that will
really kind of speed things up
if you've if you guys are following my
patreon carving project i have a
so i have like two patreon projects one
for the videos one for carving
if you're following the carving one
you'll see his his kind of work
we're designing uh more ornamental stuff
with him
uh he was a mosaic before he started
working for me he's actually an old
friend
from college that i've known you know
since i was like 17.
and uh and so he's
he's working on kind of ornamental
designs with mosaics and uh
using different patterns which will then
integrate into more elaborate carvings
and so i'm focusing on having some
some more elaborate carvings like i'm
really excited right now because uh
because jordan peterson ordered two like
three
very large uh carvings which he he said
you know make them the best that you can
like the best that you've ever done so i
always like that because it gives me a
lot of leeway to just go
nuts so we're going to integrate a lot
of the stuff where
we're um we're designing but his
commission he's going to get in two
years like
i basically took his commission because
i really really wanted to do it
because it was really elaborate but all
the other commissions i'm
sadly not taking right now hopefully in
a year or so i'll open up commissions
again
and uh
so what i need to do at first is i
basically need to free up the space
so i'm taking out just outlining the
shape and then taking out the background
as you can see this is turning this
table that turns is a huge help
someone asked i hope the video is out uh
full in the channel i will probably just
leave it on the channel
unless i say something horribly stupid
which i would be surprised that would
happen
so one of the actually exciting things
is that so this um
this workshop that i did last week that
i that i put together
um for these people in saskatoon is
basically like a
full-on online uh recorded workshop with
explanations and like three cameras
where you can see the carving from two
angles you can hear me speak so i'm
i'm actually really considering pulling
it putting it out
online uh as like an as like an online
course that i could
that i could um that i could sell that
people could
could sign up for so look out for that
in the next
i don't know when but uh hopefully i'll
have time to get that ready
but i'd really like to do that because
it's really annoying
there are a lot of really promising
people that were taking my icon carving
classes but now with kovitt everything
is just so
so dead
thunder wolf ass of gadsat has taken up
my conversation challenge
and the answer is no godzad is is
ignoring my
i actually wrote him an email too and
asked if he wanted to talk to me
um but i'm sure he must find me to be
very strange this strange christian guy
and i'm and i'm sure like he doesn't he
doesn't understand
what relevance it would have to talk to
me
someone says i bet you could have an
epic jack-o'-lantern yeah we in the in
the past few years i've actually done
that with the kids
um carved some pretty uh some pretty
intense
halloween pumpkins
that's been fun not this year though for
some reason i think this year because
we're fixing up our house
and we didn't we just didn't have time
and because of kobet and everything
halloween was almost canceled
um but usually we take the time i spend
some time with my kids and we
spend like uh like half a day you know
carving some epic pumpkins
because my both of my daughters are
quite artistic
[Applause]
so
hopefully this doesn't isn't like chalk
on a like uh
fingernails on a chalkboard for you guys
sorry
so it's a mix of so it's a mix of mallet
and then
using uh just pushing with my hand to
scrape
because the mallet will leave some like
massive uh
marks on there but if i scrape it then
then i can remove that
this dust is super toxic
it's silica dusk so it it just gets in
your lungs and
kills you so i have to be more i have to
be attentive to that
it says having storytellers here makes
me more sure
about the theory that big movies follow
jonathan um
i mean you guys probably know that i've
done a few videos with thomas from the
storyteller
uh there's a few videos that that were
actually together on
online i did a video also with them for
their channel
um on um what was it on
it was on uh
i got the name of that movie with the
big uh big robots
and uh and also thomas has edited a lot
of my
movie videos and so so we're we we get
along pretty well
for the last few years pacific rim yes
of course man i'm an idiot yeah we did
we did a video in pacific rim together
and i kept mispronouncing jaeger's i
kept saying jagers i think
and then people would criticize me
i've been so out of movies like i just
don't watch movies anymore
um and uh
i think it's because i just can't i i'm
just struggling with the with the
stories now
you know i've i made a few videos
criticizing them but it's like
do i really want to subject myself to
this all the time and so
i watched oh you know so everybody was
telling me you need
like there's like what is one division
about you know you should watch one
division you should watch one division
wouldn't like if we're trying to
understand it
and so i did i watched one division and
my goodness
it's like if you didn't think it was the
end of the world yet just watch one
division
i know and now you can be pretty sure
that it's the end of the world
i wonder like watching one division i
wonder if people
made that to give you sympathy for
people who are like burning witches
because
seriously that series is like the ending
i'm not going to spoil it for whoever
wants to watch it but the ending of that
series is so insane
like it is so insane that you wonder
what exactly are they thinking
someone asked if working alone if i
listened to music yes
i listened to i listened i liked i'd
rather listen to podcasts
um
[Music]
i listened to podcasts and i also
listened to books and so i
i either i read books on audible or
i i actually have like a reader like an
electronic reader that just reads me
pdfs
and so often i'll read books um
i'll read books while i'm working my
mind is actually pretty
available while i'm working
so storyteller says i'm at the finale
it's been confusing to say the least
yeah you're going to love the i mean
anyways you can i'd like to talk i would
be good to talk to you about it thomas
because i'm curious
i'd be curious to know what you think of
it to me it was it's just like
it's basically it's like one division is
basically
uh a defense of the matrix is what i
would call it
that's what i would say it's like
what if the matrix was a good thing or
at least justifiable
right it's like and i'm not saying it's
good but we're saying they're reasons
you know and and you know you should
understand the reasons
so that's what i think one of it is very
disturbing
you know but it's interesting like the
link between uh
between the idea of the occult and and
um
and and an artificial intelligence you
know the idea that there's some
like occult force preserving
the artificial intelligence it's like
really is that is that what you want us
to
is that the message you want to give us
because we kind of think that already
but you know we're not going to say it
out loud most of the time
um
so the first part of the carving is the
boring part it's it's actually not
it's boring in the sense that it's just
carving um
carving the halo and calling to carving
the background but it's also good
because it's uh
it's a nice uh like it gets you ready
for the carving because it's not as
doesn't ask much of you except to just
do it
[Applause]
so
so
so i want the like i want all the
background and this halo to be nice and
clean like this
so
but calvin sweetie asked if i reached
out to tim mackey with the bible project
yes i did i made that
effort i went and found the on their
email they have on their website they
have an email for uh press
like uh and so i went and wrote them an
email can explain what i'm doing and ask
them
if tim could come on the channel but
they told me that
he is not doing interviews right now
that was the answer i got
so if if anybody has an end to the bible
project
or an into god's side you need to
convince them of how important it would
be
really bad at inviting people to go on
my channel
i've been pretty much just when people
write me i
that's when i usually um
kind of have them on my channel after
they've written me that's usually been
most
mostly been how it's happened or like
some exchange on twitter or some
exchange
on social media and then it kind of
prompts me to to invite them
but yeah i probably need to be a bit
more
a bit more aggressive about that
one of the interesting things that might
be happening it's not 100 sure but
uh i might i might participate in um
with uh unbelievable that show that
british show
that kind of kind of pits believers and
atheists against each other
and so that'd be cool if that could
happen that'd be nice
so someone asked is there a ritual
prayer that you say while carving
uh no i usually usually i i
do my morning prayers and uh
you know and do the jesus prayer for a
while and then i
i come to the workshop you know
that's usually the way i do it i don't
necessarily
i think that ideally i could probably do
the jesus prayer while i'm carving
but it's just not a discipline that i've
developed
i kind of see my carving time as a as a
time to learn stuff and to read
and so
[Music]
i'm basically going over the
lines and the lines i mean the
importance of the lines is that every
line
basically is like a change of level and
so i need to
to remove some stone so that i can then
create that difference in levels that
will be there
someone else what are my thoughts on the
dietary restrictions in the old
testament
um and i think that they're interesting
in terms of understanding symbolism they
help you understand
the relationship between pure and impure
and they can help you understand
um quite a few things actually
but i don't christians don't practice
those
um christians have different
restrictions which are linked to fasting
and not eating meat itself
and so you can understand the not eating
meat
rather rather than like just the idea of
pure impure animals you can understand
the not eating meat rather
as this momentary return to the garden
because in the garden of eden
they didn't eat meat
and so you and some monks actually in
the orthodox tradition
don't eat meat in theory i mean
obviously i'm sure some do
but in theory they're not supposed to
and so right now is lent and so during
lent uh
orthodox christians don't eat any animal
products
in theory um
and so no no no eggs no
no animal fat you know none of that and
um no fish
but it depends i mean obviously people
have different different different
strictures and some people have health
care
issues that will affect or not just
health issues but sometimes also kind of
social issues will make it
very difficult to fast because the
purpose of the fast is not just
it's not just like to to practice the
rules right but it's
it's mostly to learn to to abstain
and then to kind of watch yourself
to watch yourself and realize just how
much you are a
slave of your of your passions how much
you are
you justify your own behavior and so
you know failing during lent is is
sometimes good to help you see that
you're
that you're not in control of your own
you're not totally in control of your
own self
so someone asks uh you know
lost the tradition of fasting any advice
um
i mean the early christians used to use
to fast twice a week
on wednesdays and fridays which is a
tradition which is still there
um and like i said it is there different
ways to do it depending on your
situation for example like if you can't
fast for meat for some reason
you know like it's just not possible in
your context or
whatever it is then you can you can
sometimes just do a meal a day
in the evening um so so that's a way to
fast as well
sometimes sometimes people do both like
some
some people will do just vegetables than
one meal a day
and in theory like in theory for example
you're not even in uh
during lunch you're not supposed to eat
oil like you're supposed to have veg
vegetables without oil and so like
i can't like i can't do that it's just
too hard in my
situation so
and so i don't do that so everybody has
kind of their thing
and it's good to to just be aware of it
and if you have a spiritual father to
kind of discuss it with your spiritual
father
someone says when you're done please put
a list of starter tools in the
description
the problem with this is that even if i
put a list of starter tools
all these tools are most of these tools
i made and so it's like you know this is
a
this is actually a punching tool which i
gra grinds down
because it has high high carbon steel
so i just grind it down to make it the
shape i want like if you look at this
tool
for example this is just a wood chis a
wood uh
um i guess not called a a chisel
yeah i get a guess a wood chisel it's a
flat one and
and then i round it off like i round off
the top
a little bit just because it to make it
do what i want it to do
so so it's tough like this is a wood
this is actually just a wood carving
tool it's like a
fel a fell uh
wood carving tool that works really well
for small spots
so it's hard to write down like what
what you need because
most of my tools for stone at least i've
made or
kind of grab from here and there
wood carving tools are more standard
that's why like when i teach for example
like the carving class i did online
that i'm going to put out there is
probably going to be it's good it's a
wood
wood clasp because it's it's just it's
more simple and it's
you can get material very easily like
this stone even if
even if i gave you the tools too i don't
know where you would get the stone
like i import this stone from kenya and
so you need to get something analogous
which
i'm not sure where you would get because
this is a
kind of soapstone a stea type but it's
not uh
it's it's a it's pretty dense it's not
as as
porous and as soft as the stone
for example that i could get here in
canada um
like inuit inuit um so like native
communities here up north you know
kind of eskimo i guess you would call
them they carve uh
soapstone but the soaps on the carve is
very different it's like this dark green
soapstone
i often feel like i'm the luckiest
person in the world because
i get to think about things and make and
make youtube videos and write about
more let's say hi or abstract
ideas and then i get to like come into
my workshop and just bang at a piece of
stone with a mallet
for a few hours so it's a nice uh
it's a nice balance that's what it feels
like sometimes
so i want to create these three these
three fold these three steps
[Music]
it's either three-fold here in her
homophorian her
her veil and then three steps on this
side so that's kind of what i'm work
that's what i'm trying to create
so
someone says i was able to done my first
oca liturgy just excited to share it
with you that's awesome
daniel demarco is that right
so where are where are you daniel where
like what what state are you
attending liturgy
hey allister roberts is there that's
awesome nice to see you alistair
i wanna i wanna have you back on my
channel by the way i keep thinking that
i should write you
and then we should have another
discussion and then i then i just
then i just forget because i'm like that
but if you'd like i would
it would be really cool to have you back
on the channel
so daniel demarco says northern new
jersey nice
it's good to know you can go like we
just until until
two days ago we had an eight o'clock
curfew and we could only be ten people
in church
and so because of that we would have to
like trade off we would you would sign
up on a list and
they would prioritize people that
weren't there the week before that you
know that hadn't gone
yet and so it's been kind of hit and
miss i've been
going to church every two weeks pretty
much
but um so they just changed that
a few days ago and so now it's a hundred
people which means that
for us at least my church is pretty much
gonna be open now for everybody
um so i'm pretty excited about that i'm
probably probably going to be able to go
to uh
enunciation this week
so greg holm asks do you do printmaking
as well or just carving no i don't do
printmaking i mean i'm doing
some drawings i'm thinking about doing
print making
that's definitely something that i'm
considering just because
it's like right now i have i guess i
have the problem
that the demand for what i'm doing is
too high and i can't um
i can't uh make
enough things and i also don't want to
raise my prices too much because i'm
making sacred art like
it's not like i'm making secular art so
i need to be careful and so i thought
maybe if i did printmaking i could have
things that are
still reasonably priced but i could make
i could make more
i
uh
[Laughter]
[Music]
this is kind of funky
see well
sorry i feel like it's not the best view
of this
what if i first time technical
i feel like i could give you guys a
better view of this maybe if i did this
was that i think that's closer
yeah i think it's better all right i
think that's better all right so the
tricky thing with these with this
carving
and tell you the little secret of this
carving is that
her fold her her um
her veil folds so when it folds it goes
it goes around and back so this is
always the tricky thing so when i'm
teaching carving to people
this is where everybody gets confused
because you have to show that the veil
is
on this side here and then it goes
underneath there um
so but it's actually some of the fun
part to me
at least is creating those relationships
so z asks me what i think of tarkovsky's
rubella oh yeah i mean tarkovsky is
amazing and i think for sure
he's definitely worth spending time with
you know if he's definitely for people
who want to kind of understand
how to create uh
or to bring about some of the questions
you know that
about the christian ethos in movies
in a deeper way like not just a not not
a superficial
you know propagandistic way but i think
that
tchaikovsky for sure i don't even know
if he was a christian
but he definitely was imbibed with a lot
of um
or he is he's not dead is he i don't
even know
that he's imbibed with kind of orthodox
ethos so
someone asked if if i have something to
propose
to learn about orthodoxy a basic thing i
mean i always propose
uh there's a book called the orthodox
way by metropolitan
callisto's where it's called the
orthodox way and it's a very it's a book
written for
westerners and so it's written to kind
of help people understand
what um what the spiritual life is and
what the vision of the spiritual life
in orthodoxy is
it's very easily accessible
so someone asked if i listened to music
i guess i didn't answer that properly
the other day yeah the other day like
just before i i listened to
i listen mostly to podcasts in books but
once in a while i listen to music i used
to listen to a lot more music but
i would say in the past like seven
seven years maybe i've i don't listen to
a lot of music anymore
like whatever time i had to listen i
listened to um
to uh content but if i like
when i'm sleepy let's say during the day
if i'm tired and i'm
trying to carve but i'm just kind of not
being able to focus
and uh i feel kind of drained then i'll
listen to music
someone asked if i listened to and then
they asked me if i listened to uh
dirt poor robin's uh music and yes i do
listen to dirt robin's music i'm
i'm actually enjoying it quite a bit
these days like in the car and stuff
i'll put it on
so storytellers asked what i think of
teres terence malik and his
and uh and his last movie hidden life
i haven't watched it because the thing
is the terence malik movies
i really struggle with them
but so many people have told me about a
hidden light that i probably should
watch it
but it's like what was that other one
with the dinosaurs
um i really struggled with that movie
um i feel like there's at least the ones
i've watched i feel like there's a lot
of meandering
but i should i should probably watch a
hidden life
like i said i really don't watch a lot
of movies and it's weird because when i
do
it's i'd rather watch like a stupid like
a big stupid movie
um with my kids because my kids
i usually now watch most of the stuff i
watch i watch it with my kids because
it's kind of like
also a time to just kind of hang out
with them
so someone asked if i saw silence by
martin scorsese yes i did
an interesting story i actually watched
silence by martin scorsese for the first
time
uh at a retreat uh
for orthodox priests they invited me to
come
do like to be like the speaker at their
retreat
[Music]
and one of the things they wanted to do
is to like watch a movie and then have
me interpret it
and i never seen silence i watched it
with them um
and i have to say it was very disturbing
movie
i find it very disturbing
movies like that they're disturbing
because they actually
it's like you'd almost would rather
people not make movies about christian
subjects
if they're going to be weird about it
it's all
i'd rather they didn't because when they
do then it it comes
close to something you know for example
like they're trying to come close to the
idea of
of self-sacrifice and of and the idea
of uh let's say the love of others but
they
they they have this weird then they they
present this weird thing where it's
it's the almost the idea that if you
love others then you will deny christ
out of your love for others and it's
like ah
no you know what sorry that's not this
doesn't work
it's just i just i'm not getting on
board and you're with your little moral
dilemma that you're trying to present to
me here
uh and this idea that like christ would
would want
would want someone to deny him uh just
very
very very disturbing um
so i didn't i didn't particularly like
that
sorry if i ruined the movie for you guys
i'm like i
never ask me about never ask me like uh
about uh
about movies because i i really don't
care about the spoilers thing like i i
often don't care about
being spoiled on the movie myself
because that's not why i watch movies
or why i mention why i would spend time
on it and so
and so sorry if i spoiled the movie for
you guys
yeah someone says they highly recommend
the island yeah the island is very good
i really really like that
someone asked me who are my favorite
historic iconographers
you know it's funny that you asked that
because i really don't have
i don't have that vision of iconography
so it's like if i
because for example like an icon carving
the the the iconographers aren't known
so you could say that like let's say my
favorite uh
my favorite iconographers are whoever it
is that carved those
um those like 9th 10th century
ivories that were done in the byzantine
court after the
after iconoclasm uh it's like those i
feel like
those carvings i base a lot of my work
on
whatever was developed in those carvings
and so
that's pretty much how i see it you know
and
so but i mean let's say
i really like
i really like uh let's say pancelinos
because he has he kind of has uh
volume to his work
um and so it's interesting to think
about it in terms of carving for myself
and so of course i love rhubarb's icons
and i love that period of uh
russian iconography as well
but i also really love western medieval
art and so
you know there's some like for example
the if you think of the um
a lot of my work is is also kind of
based on
what i guess you could call the kind of
10th century
12th century
byzantine normand uh synthesis i don't
know how else you could call it
like whatever whatever whatever kind of
movement created the
the great uh the great churches in
sicily
um those that moment
i think is a really kind of crucial
moment
um and so a lot of my work is based on
that and it's it's something it's a very
there's a universal aspect to that that
style
that got developed at that time
so one of the things that one of my
contentions i would say
is that although we live in a time of
mixture
and a time of confusion you would say
there's also an opportunity
in that moment which is that whatever it
is that
gives us the mixture and the the uh
the confusion uh there's something in
that
which can also bring about a kind of
synthesis
you know so if you think about the
problem of iconography right now
is that it's not i mean the problem the
reality of iconography is that
in every other period of time in the
history of the of iconography
people would learn from some master and
would
would maybe travel with them and then
see churches that were done and then
would
have sketch books with the different um
the different subjects inside and so
that's how they would
learn and so like the way we learn is we
have access to all the very best icons
still available online and we can flip
through them
like we flip through a catalog and so
that has a massive
effect on our psyche and the way we read
art and the way we understand the
tradition
and so and so it there's something
that's nefarious about that
of having access to all the very best
icons
and at your fingertips but there's also
something uh like in the juxtaposition
there's also something which is
kind of weird and and uh hybrid about it
but i think that in that there's also
the possibility
of having some distance of kind of
looking at things from a distance
which is alienating but can also which
but can
also bring about a kind of synthesis and
so that's kind of
the um the vision that i have for what
i'm doing and also
kind of the vision i have for the best
like the vision i have of the best
iconographers that are working today
which is to create a synthetic
iconographic
style and like in a graphic language you
could say um
so it doesn't mean that it's it doesn't
mean that we it's all gonna be the same
actually there will be there's
difference in there but um
[Music]
that's been my approach at least so
there's an ass like for example like in
my carving there's an aspect of my
carving
uh let's say the way i make faces
which is which is actually probably more
akin to something which is more erratic
or more
schematized you would say something you
could find maybe in like western
medieval art or maybe
a hint of coptic or kind of syrian
iconography in the sense of a kind of
simpler less
less um idiosyncratic aspect in the face
um and so it i think it has something to
do with
stone itself like that's that the
material also lends itself to that kind
of interpretation
so someone asked what can you say about
geometric patterns
uh as constituting art as you see in
islamic art
i really love geometric patterns i i'm
not good at them
in in the sense that they require a
certain mindset which i don't think i
really have
like and i you know
there's a lot of islamic art which is
very beautiful and very
very impressive and so to ask that is
is is an interesting idea so for example
like
the idea if anybody would say that they
have a problem with that
you know it would be extremely
problematic because
the for example the in most traditional
orthodox churches
that would have been in the
mediterranean the the uh the rugs on the
floor
would probably have come from islamic
countries um because of that beautiful
ornamental uh capacity that they had
you know in terms of geometry in terms
of repetitive patterns
and so i have no problem with that at
all in fact i think that
it's interesting to to take
some uh like an islamic manuscript for
example like to take some of that
ornamentation
and um
to use it in my in my designs or the
designs that i'm working with my
assistant on
like we there there's always a
discussion you know
there's an idea that people have in
terms of let's say the medieval world as
this kind of isolated world where
nobody was in contact with anybody but
that is not the case there was always a
discussion
you know between between these different
cultures and styles and
and so there was definitely different
influences going around
so there's definitely an influence on
let's say between
byzantine art and and persian miniature
you know between uh byzantine art to
persian miniature to mogul
indian miniature to so there's all these
like relationships that
create themselves you know
so hagia sophia
the pattern of the cross the dome and
the cross or the dome and the square
was really perfected in in christianity
with justinian
and then became the model for pretty
much all of islamic
architecture you know and so islamic
architecture is really like a dome on a
square
dome on an octagon
and then coming back the other way then
the all of the
a lot of the ornamentation the the very
powerful geometric work that was done
by islamic artists then kind of flooded
back into
western miniature and then also
byzantine miniature as well
[Music]
so
so i have some tools that i've rounded
out more you guys want to see
these are really more round and so if i
want to create uh
some like a dip
it's one of the tricks one of the tricks
of low relief carving is that you want
to
you want to use as little space as
possible to
to nonetheless give a sense of the form
so a way to do it sometimes is to create
these little bowls
with an edge on each side and then that
edge on each side will
will emphasize the light more will kind
of make the the
form pop out
so
[Laughter]
someone asks common sense culture asking
for projects like this i often have to
start over
and how's that change since you started
um to be honest i almost never
have to start over
[Music]
when i started i made a few mistakes at
the beginning like in the very first
year
um but they weren't in the carving they
were actually like i
for example like twice this is just
insane it shows how
uh i was making uh i was making a cross
for a priest and it was a cross that was
supposed to go into a wooden frame
and at first i thought you know if i
make the fit nice and
like nice and tight it'll look really
good because it'll just kind of tightly
go in there
and so i made the frame and i would
carve out the frame and then
insert the cross inside and so twice i
made the frame
too tight and then when i pushed the
cross in it just it broke
after i had carved the whole thing um
and so i don't do that anymore
i don't make that mistake anymore uh and
the other times where i've made like
massive mistakes
have been uh like sometimes with these
these stone carvings
and they're big i'll remove the
background with a router
and so sometimes like uh the router bit
was like too loose or something
and uh and then when i'm taking out the
background it would like dig
in way too much so those are the kind of
mistakes that i made
but the thing with carving is that if if
you're careful you can always
fix your mistakes it takes it takes work
because you kind of have to carve the
whole thing down around it
but it's actually quite forgiving so i
really
i really panic
as you can see like when i get to the
little details when i get to the end i'm
not carving with the mallet anymore
i carve with the mallet at the beginning
to do the
the basic forms and the the levels but
then when i get to um
when i get to the finishing of of
the form then i use a knife
[Music]
so someone asks can anyone make icons
and to be honest i think that i think
that anybody can
let's say approach iconography in terms
of
learning about it about you know
learning to uh
to make to learning the process
and even maybe learning to make icons i
don't think that it's necessarily
restricted
but in order to if you want to make
icons for the church
if you want to make icons uh that that
you
that will be used in the church and that
will be used for that people will
venerate
then i would i would really suggest that
you have
the permission of your of your bishop or
at least of your priest or of your
spiritual father
um just because it's very important and
and uh there are certain there are
certain rules like there are there
are just certain things you have to know
and that you have to be careful about
and so
it's not like it's not a willy-nilly
thing like you can't just go
you can't just do whatever you want and
so i mean and sometimes i have very
let's say um well-intentioned people who
send me things that
they want me to comment on and and they
look nice in the sense that they're
technically proficient but
they they're lacking in the language
they're lacking in the kind of the
the unsaid language of what makes an
icon an icon
um and
and that's a difficult discussion right
in iconography because
obviously it's all about patterns and
understanding and interpreting what is
essential and what is a detail
in terms of what the what have has been
given to us by the
by those before us and so that's a
discussion that's live
in iconography right now where some
iconographers
tend to want to copy directly like not
just copy but
let's say like even though the the
drawing i did for this
for some iconographers this would be
this would be
like a faux pas i should trace
a pattern that's that that already
exists like not draw my own
um whereas others will go the totally
opposite route which is
to be extremely flexible about what's
possible and what's not possible and
and to kind of want to have the
their own personal style and all that
stuff
so the discussion is quite is quite live
right now
in the world of iconography
[Music]
so someone asked how much these little
icons are these little icons are
three hundred dollars but i'm not i
don't like
this is actually a commission for a
while what i was doing is i knew that
because if you order like a bigger thing
that has a lot of detail then it ends up
being
expensive and i knew that not everybody
could afford it and i also knew that a
lot of people
um they don't they don't they can't
necessarily wait for a very long time
and so
for a while i was making regularly
making these little carvings
and then putting them for sale on social
media
but it's like once you once you realize
that you've got two years waiting list
it's it's
hard to justify making these carvings
also
so right now what i'm doing for people
who want kind of more inexpensive
carvings for me
i encourage them to uh to be involved in
the in the patreon project because
i'm uh what we do is we we develop these
uh
these these ornamental carvings and
these kind of semi-figurative carvings
with
angels and uh different animals and
stuff
and uh and then every what we're gonna
do we've done it already once
is that every once in a while like a few
times a year we're going to just sell
them
and uh those who are supporting the
patreon project will
have have first dibs uh
obviously there are people giving at
high levels that will get an actual
carving so we save carvings for them
but then but then others will get like
first dibs and then after that then i
put it on social media and then people
can
can buy the other ones
so jonathan andreas jonathan as a father
as an artist have you used sacred art
and the spiritual development catechesis
of your kids as they've grown
um and so i mean obviously
i've always tried like let's say there
was a feast or
a bible story when we let's say we're
reading a bible story or we're
coming back from liturgy and it was a
certain uh gospel reading or a certain
feast or whatever i'd always try to
point out the icon with the kids and
kind of ask them to look at it to tell
me what they see
to kind of try to analyze the elements
in the icon
but my kids are not interested in
drawing icons at least
not yet maybe one day who knows but you
know
in terms of then just being a dad then i
i definitely have given my kids uh
drawing classes um and uh
and so we've done proportions and
you know drawing from uh observation
different different uh
different ways of teaching drawing
my 13 year old daughter is basically
like obsessed with anime now and that's
all she
she she cares to draw or to hard to be
involved with
it's kind of a little disturbing but you
know i i
can't i was when i was 13 i was like
obsessed with batman or whatever
or like comic books so i can't totally
can't totally blame her
so deluxe says he has a twitch channel
where he st
he streams fish tanks interesting yeah i
mean i'm not very good at the whole
streaming thing
i'm really not good technically for
carving for for
for the youtube stuff
so i should i probably could actually
use some
help in figuring out how to do this i
don't know like what you guys think how
many people are watching like 382.
that's actually not bad so maybe it's
something i could do more often i don't
know what you guys think
it's for me obviously if i'm carving
it's not a big deal i can just
can just have the camera running and
then talk to you guys while i'm carving
i feel less less lonely yeah right
i never feel lonely when i'm carving
[Music]
yeah thomas from storytellers has one
more batman video
i know i've made way too many batman
videos and i know that i made way too
many batman videos because the last one
i did
like not a lot of people watch it i
think they're like what
really or is it are they maybe they even
think that wait i saw this before just
another batman video
uh but no my batman videos everybody
should watch them because
because i deal with important issues
all right so now we're moving in the
face so we're coming into interesting
things
so she's wearing she the mother god has
two veils on
she has a mage she has a veil on over
her
her head that is what you see and then
underneath she has uh
she has like someone said it's called
the snood which i don't like that word
so i don't know if that's really what
it's called if someone knows what it's
called
it's like a veil it's just a covering
over the hair so she has this one
covering over her hair
and then on top she has like a veil
so you never actually see mary's hair
you never see the mother of god
of god's hair in in orthodox icons
[Music]
[Music]
i'm actually going to do this shoulder
first
hey mahatma sat was there amazing work
thanks for the great content
it's good to see you here so mahasadva
if you you probably
you guys may have seen him on twitter on
instagram he is uh
he's known for his his kanye west
paintings
so he's actually given a painting to uh
one of
his paintings to kanye and kanye follows
him
on twitter which everybody is jealous
about so uh yeah it's good to see you
[Music]
someone asked do byzantine catholics
have different
styles than eastern orthodox and so
that's a very complicated question
because it's it's there's a historical
situation
which happened and it didn't it did
happen
through byzantine catholics before it
happened
in uh in the orthodox world which is
that
in the 18th 19th century
i would say maybe starting a little bit
before the
the style of iconography became very
western
in greece and in russia
as well also in the slavic countries
and so there so the traditional let's
say practice and style of iconography
almost vanished it was almost gone and
um and interestingly enough then
it also led to a kind of breakdown of
of icons themselves right and so kind of
moving into secularism
the the the idea of the icon or the
importance of the icon
started to disappear as well and so
there were always some practices but
people practicing the traditional style
for the ancient style but they were few
and and it's in the 20th century
actually
that uh that the style the ancient style
of icon painting was restored
through people like uh leonard uspensky
and photos contoglu in in greece
who kind of rediscovered the ancient
style and then tried to help people
understand it
you know it's one of those things
sometimes i talk about um
how you know a few decades ago
people wouldn't even have understood
what i was talking about and i really do
believe that
because there was like a weird
materialist blindness
and so i think that it's the same with
with icons i think that
there came a strange blindness where
people really did
think that you know representing
uh reality in a in
in a certain manner was
was the only way that you could
represent it or was the the only
possible reason why you would represent
it
and they didn't have the capacity just
because of a weird
kind of philosophical historical
blindness
to understand the value of more
symbolic manners of representation and
and so in the 20th century with the
actually the
the kind of post-world war ii
beginning of the breakdown i guess you
could call it of modernism
um that's when the possibility of seeing
traditional icons again started to
reappear
and so so there are really some pioneers
and they made mistakes i would say they
made mistakes in their theory and they
made mistakes in their
in their practice and they're actually
being
they're actually quite under attack
right now in the world of iconography
and so there's a whole group of scholars
and iconographers that are attacking the
uh
the the say the pioneers of of uh
of the modern icon movement
but um
but i think despite their mistakes i
think what they
offered us was really invaluable in
terms of a capacity to see
that was lost and uh so
i definitely support
the traditional style
but it it led it did lead to some
excesses
for example like some people would say
things like you know if an image is
painted in a
in a western style or in like a kind of
post renaissance style then it's
not an icon and i think that's really a
dangerous
route to go because you know
i i would say it you have to see it in
terms of hierarchy rather than see it as
an on off switch
and i i think it's dangerous to uh
to decide what what what really will be
an
icon in terms of how it
affects the world you so you can accept
it for example
like a really western painted icon can
can still be a center of veneration and
can still be a place where
people encounter you know the a mystery
while while saying that you think that
traditional icons are superior
theologically and that they should that
they should
be promoted and
be preferred let's say to the ancient
style
i need to do
i need to put this in the middle i think
because i
i think because the image is not in the
middle when i turn it
keeps like it turns up and down
is better
yeah this is better sorry this will be
this will be easier to watch now because
i didn't realize that because i i hadn't
put it in the middle of the board it was
like spinning up and down for you guys
so someone says stopping homeschool to
watch this come on this
is homeschool this isn't stopping home
school
that's what that is is because the nose
is the
is the highest point on the face and i
always free that up
first
makes to make sure that that's on the
highest point in the carving as well
it can be equal to other points but it
definitely has to be
one of the highest points
[Music]
so anders brass that says what do you
think about flow state any symbolic
insight
um
i mean i don't have a i don't have a
problem with the idea of a flow state i
think
one of the things i'm worried about when
people talk about flow state is that
is is that they somehow want to
say that that's the mystical experience
or that the
this kind of integrated
moment that you have that that's the
mystical experience and i think that
that's a little
dangerous because i think that maybe
it's it's like a lot of things it it can
be a kind of
can kindle your
your interest or it can kindle your
sense that there's something more
that there's a possibility of having
higher
states or higher experiences but
i don't think that when you read what
the mystics go through
it's like that's that's that's not
that's not it doesn't limit itself to
that that's for sure
like they the the states that they reach
are much
higher and much you know
so i think that it's it's great you know
when you're
when you're praying or you know even
carving sometimes
i definitely do reach that kind of flow
state when i'm carving
um
[Music]
you can really start to see the face now
up here
someone says jns77 says i'm pretty sure
you can enter into a flow state
while you're killing people in the
battlefield it may be transcended but it
might not necessarily be good for you
that's an awesome point yeah
yeah actually i'm pretty sure that many
warrior cultures saw
uh killing people or just this
this state like let's say the kind of
this this trans-personal state that you
could reach during battle to be
like a mystical thing that's for sure
like the whole idea of the berserker and
you know the idea that the berserker
kind of loses himself
and becomes a vehicle
[Laughter]
and also one of the like let's say one
of the really important aspects of
christian or orthodox spirituality is
that
you're not supposed to pay attention to
the states like you're not supposed to
pay you're not supposed to attend to the
spiritual states that you reach
you're actually supposed to be
suspicious of them and to not
to not dwell on them so it's not like
you can't reach them it's not that you
don't things won't happen to you and you
won't reach these
kind of ecstatic states but but uh you
should definitely definitely shouldn't
like
search for them search out for them and
you definitely shouldn't
um attend to them
because you're going higher like you're
reaching for
for the the last or the ultimate one
which is
theosis which is illumination
seeing the seeing the divine light
hmm
so someone asks
charlie longoria asked what carving
skill was the most difficult
for you to master um
hmm
i would say it's all clothing is always
the hardest
[Music]
clothing is really it's like having
the right level of subtlety in clothing
because
it's not just about carving it's about
drawing and about understanding form and
about
um and so it's like you can always be a
better
you can always be better at clothing
when you're you're an iconographer i
think for painting is probably the same
and so i think that that's the that's
always my challenge
is is to try to to keep when i sometimes
i look at some of the carvings i did in
the past
and i'm like wow i really man that
clothing is really nice and
some reason i can't reach that anymore
um
are the other elements i feel like
they're more available to me like the
face and
um you know let's say car in the hands
are carving different other aspects
one of the things that i've actually
recently learned or recently
acquired in terms of carving i would say
it's been about a year
maybe a year and a half is i used to
sand all my carvings like
a lot and so i would i would carve
especially in stone like i would carve
the whole thing and then with like
sandpaper i would like go over
every single edge to make it smooth and
everything and i remember it was andrew
gould who's a
for those who don't know he's uh he's a
building designer who designs churches
he kept telling me why do you send your
carving so much he said
just carve it like don't sand it and and
at first i was
i didn't want to do that because you can
also fix things with sanding you know
when
you feel a little uneasy but most
recently
in the past i would say about a year a
little maybe a little more
i've actually stopped sanding most of
the
carving and so all the clothing i leave
and
the hands these different parts and i'll
sand maybe sometimes just the surface of
the face especially if it's a if it's a
woman
to kind of make it smooth but uh but all
the rest i leave like the rocks the
background the cities and everything i
don't sand i just
carve straight up and don't don't touch
it
and it looks better and uh so it both
looks better and saves time which is
which hey you can't complain you can't
complain when something does that
so i'm actually right now someone's
talking about the soap stone that i'm
carving from kenya it's called kisi
stone
uh and it's from the it's from the kisi
area
in uh in kenya mostly from
a town called tobacco and around that
town named tobacco
and i one of the reasons i discovered
this stone is because i lived there for
several months
with my wife and kids when we were
living in kenya
and that's where i learned to carve this
stone
and so i was taught
to uh to uh to to carve this and then
when i got back from kenya i really kind
of threw myself into
into it
i'm actually right now um ordering a
a shipment of stones so
i'm just hoping there will be like
problems with
kogit and whatever but for now it seems
like it's it's
it's going
so is it me are there more people in the
in the live stream now than there are
when we do the q a
which is surprising interesting it might
be because it's during the day as well
i'm thinking maybe that's what it is
or maybe i should just should just i
just should do these instead of
instead of the q and a's be less
exhausting man those q a sometimes
when i finish i have like a mix of like
exhaustion and exhilaration and so
i'm super tired after the q a's but then
i can't go to bed i can't sleep because
i've
had like a weird mental rush
[Laughter]
[Music]
someone says do the q a while carving
that's exact i don't know if i could i
don't know if i could manage it because
i mean i don't think i could i could
probably make a mistake in the carving
because some of the questions you guys
asked me
during the q and a's are like
they're they're they're tough questions
and sometimes the kind of question that
i have to be careful when i answer not
to
not to totally put my foot in my mouth
[Laughter]
add more light here
no that's way too much light for you
guys gonna get blinded
oh it's better like this i think yeah
sorry i wanted to add more light but it
just
washed away everything
someone says it's actually amazing
you're doing this with single chisel
uh you know it's like i actually i'm
such i'm i'm
not a tools guy i really don't i'm not a
big tools guy
i'm not a very uh practical person which
which
might surprise people you know it's like
i can't i'm not good at construction i'm
not good at
uh you know renovation and all the kind
of stuff guys do i'm i don't
understand cars um
and so because of that i never i just
kind of do with what i have
and i and i rarely do i
spend a lot of time thinking of how i
could do it in a better way like
how i could make it and
save time or have a better tool or have
the right tool or so i just kind of if i
can do it whatever tool i have in my
hand
um then i'll just go ahead and also like
i'm not systematic
and so sometimes i'll do the same thing
with a different tool
and it's only after i'm done that i
realize that i've done that
so patrick morrison asked where i get my
references for my carvings
um and so it's a mix of uh
of places i think i talked about a
little bit a little earlier
i i mostly base my work
like let's say the there's these really
high
carvings that were done in the 10th 11th
century
after iconoclasm they're ivories they're
sometimes called the romanos ivories
um and so there's a whole tradition of
of ivories which came about after
iconoclasm
and i would say that those are really
like for an
icon carver they're the place to look
because that's where the language got
really developed there are certain
things earlier than that but
after iconoclasm is when really
you know i would say everything we we
understand of icons
uh really really took shape and so
those are my go-to like those are the
those are my basic
uh reference points
but then uh i also look at obviously
later ivories
but also western western medieval
carving and so let's say the cathedrals
the uh the the cathedrals in france
the uh late romanesque early gothic
cathedrals
and the late romanesque early gothic
ivories in terms of uh in terms of style
and uh and so that's mostly where i get
my
my influence or what where i look to to
how to interpret
so because because icon painting in a
way is a marginal art in the church
in the orthodox church then for sure its
influence i influence my work is
influenced by icon painting
so one of the things that i felt that
had happened
is that icon painting had developed
certain tropes
that became pretty universal in terms of
uh
in terms of of iconography not 100
universal but i was a pretty universal
say a way of doing the eyes a way of
doing the
the the glance the stare of the person
the icons
we kind of recognize the better icons as
having certain
certain ways of doing eyes and and
hands and all this stuff whereas in
carving it felt like it was all over the
place and
a lot of those better tropes didn't
develop
because it was marginal and because you
know ivory carving basically almost
stopped
after constantinople fell
and so i also tried to adapt some of the
better
aspects of icon painting to carving
so that's been one of my one of my goals
or one of my
how can i say this like one of the
things that motivates what i'm doing
is to take is to take some of the better
developments in icon painting and adapt
them to carving
because there's some things you can't do
in a carving so
it's like i'm not the only person who
does that i would say most icon carvers
will use
uh we'll use paintings
icon paintings as some as their models
but a lot of them don't think it through
and so one of the things that like i
said those early
ivories they're like 11th 10th 11th
century ivories
they give you like a basic map and then
you can use those
as a ground on which to build to then uh
adapt it to new
to new um ways of of uh
based on the painting so one of the
things i feel like was never really well
done in
in eastern in eastern iconographic
tradition in terms of carving was i feel
like the faces are always
are not great like they're they're kind
of mediocre
and they were more successful in kind of
western
medieval art let's say like late
romanesque art the way they did the eyes
in a very kind of simple stylistic way
and um and so i tend to i ten so what i
did is i looked at those
and then joined them with the more
byzantine clothing and byzantine
um proportions i would say
and just iconology
so deluxe says i sent a message you a dm
on twitter unless there's a different
way
uh you would like to be contacted uh i
mean i i can check
i don't like i don't always see all the
dms because some of them are
some of them are if if you're not if i
don't follow you then they kind of go
into
spam or whatever it's called or message
requests or whatever uh so i don't
always see them and i don't always
answer i'm sorry
especially since the jordan peterson
interview i've been really
overwhelmed by messages and it's very
touching because
a lot of people are writing me really
wonderful messages but
i i just can't i just can't answer
everybody
um and also like a lot of people are
asking me to go on their podcast and
and and i underst like i i sympathize
but it's hard because
those take up a lot of time and you know
and also because everybody has a podcast
like ever
i have a podcast so it's not i'm not
complaining about that but everybody has
a podcast so it's hard to
it's hard to to
yeah it's hard to answer those messages
in the positive let's say
but i'll i can check your message and
see what you say
so you can really see i think you can
really see the face
kind of appearing pretty
clearly
you know it's coming along
and so next step is going to be
the eyes
huh
as you can see i basically carved the
eye socket first to give myself some
shape
so it's shaping the eye automatically
then i can fit it with it later but
someone says do icon nfts why would i
need to do icon nfts if i have a
physical object
that i can just sell
not sure how that would be like how how
would that even work
someone says any advice for an aspiring
iconographer i have a chance to take
some lessons under i cannot
an iconography naturally monastery
should i
seek a blessing uh i mean
i would say it's it's always useful to
have a blessing for what you're doing
uh like i said i don't think you
actually need the pro like a permission
of your priest to learn to
to to paint icons if you're interested
in it
it's probably a good idea to talk about
it with your spiritual father
but for sure if you're going to be
making icons for the church
or making them like besides just
practicing and learning
making them for veneration then i would
suggest that you be a little more
deliberate about that and maybe
in fact do uh you know ask a blessing of
your
priest or of your bishop
so my advice to you is to practice
that's the advice you could give a given
artist i would say
my advice to most iconographers is
is uh learn to draw like really learn to
draw because
people get caught up in the technical
part of
icon painting and they they get caught
up in the id because you can trace a
pattern like
and so because of that a lot of
iconographers don't learn to
to draw properly and uh it's like i
don't care
how good your pattern is if you don't
know how to draw
i can tell in your icon and because
there's a there's like a there's an
uneasiness about
there's i don't know how to explain it
it's like when you paint when you know
how
um and so i really suggest that people
should learn to draw and
when i meet draw i don't mean even just
draw icons i mean learn to draw learn
learn how to and so nice learning all
kinds of even
learning to draw from nature uh you know
learning to
to uh learning proportions learning to
draw uh
you know from like how to do
illustrations you know how to draw hands
how to draw feet how to draw
all of that is something which will be
useful to you
and to be honest like that is really
what will always separate
the real like kind of more professional
iconographer from the amateur
is a capacity to draw
another advice too is i would say if
you're learning to paint icons
uh be careful like be careful because
you'll often have people who don't let's
say have a sensitivity to quality
will if they hear that you're you're
painting icons or right away say well
can you paint an icon for me like can
you paint
can you paint an icon for a church
because they want cheap like they don't
like paying for
for art uh and so i would say be very
wary of that because
just because you took one icon painting
class or two or three it doesn't mean
that you
you can paint the level of icons that
should be in the church and
and uh you know it i think that kind of
amateur
spirit explains a lot of the bad
bad icons that we find in churches being
used in being
being part of the being actually part of
the liturgy
it's because people kind of improvise
themselves
someone says 300 is too cheap you know
it's a tricky thing the icon
the icon uh world because you
you're making objects for people to use
in their prayer life and so
yeah i'm not making icons um
i'm not making images just for
consumption or fan art or you know
whatever
or for a gallery and so i have to be i
have to be like
attentive to that and be careful about
that and
you know it's weird because i always
kind of said that i tried to make my
it's like i can make i i've made icons
that are ten thousand dollars like
that take forever and take months and
like i'm willing to to
charge for really expensive time
consuming and
and difficult icons but i think it's
important
that these little icons have a
have a kind of reasonable price because
because yeah because it's you know
everybody needs icons to pray with so
it's like i meant i'm as touched to know
that someone
you know someone who has a you know a
little job and
or two jobs and is you know struggling
in life will nonetheless like put a
little bit of money aside to be able to
buy
a real icon instead of getting a print
and have that kind of just be part of
their
life to me that's really touching so um
so i want to try to keep
something accessible for for anybody
and you know in the end
in the end god has blessed me like in so
many ways like
you know so i have nothing
to comp like i'm i'm fine you know like
i'm totally fine
so someone asked if i use gold leaf i do
but not always
so if if if a client wants gold leaf i
can use it but i don't it's not
systematic
so if if it's it's like an extra step
and it's a it's a pretty
for stone it's a time it's a time
consuming step it'll take uh
it'll take me like a few hours to put on
the
at least an hour an hour and something
to to to add the um
to add the gold
if you go to my website you'll see
you'll see um
examples with gold in them
[Music]
all right so as you can see it's it's i
mean it's coming along pretty nicely
it's almost it's ghost it's not almost
done but at least the uh
the the basic work is almost done
there's always some fiddling to do in
the end to make it
really nice but i would say you can
enough that you can really see the
the face
so
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
i foreign it's weird
okay this
is
she probably heard me speak french to my
wife there
because my workshop is like right behind
my right behind my uh
my house
and it's my son's birthday today 16 he's
16.
and so my wife was like
because we we actually celebrated his
birthday during the weekend
but she's like we should still do
something and a little something special
for him
and i agree i have to figure that out
it's been really tough for the kids on
with kovid did you turning 16
and you know it's really hard to see
your friends
then everybody's nervous and it's
actually technically like the kids
aren't allowed nobody's allowed to go in
anybody's house
here so it's just been very frustrating
all right now let's do the nose
sorry for that sound it gets it makes a
really weird sound
oh
my god
so someone asks uh max
heideri asks think for all the content
which version of the bible should i read
does it matter
i personally prefer the king james yeah
i'm a big fan of the king james myself
just because i grew up with it and
you know i'm just used to the
formulation
[Music]
and so i don't really i would say
it's best to avoid those bibles that are
too technical
um in the sense of uh
that have all the footnotes and all that
stuff in terms of
scholarly opinion about texans i really
dislike those bibles
um and so i would say king james is
is fine with me a lot of people would
say that at least for the old testament
you should read this the
the seventy the septuagint but you know
you can get the orthodox study bible
which is good
but we're kind of we're kind of we're
ruined in a way now because
you know when i'm reading let's say i'm
reading scripture in terms of uh
studying scripture then i always read
like different versions of the same
verse and then you know
go on bible hub and then check out the
the interlinear version and and so it's
it's
we're pretty we're actually pretty lucky
to be able to do that
and so we're it's less in danger
of giving in to uh kind of propaganda
that can be in translations
but if you listen to
the the lord spirits podcast like you'll
hear father stephen complain all the
time about how
most bible translations have have a have
like an agenda and
in the sense they they've had the agenda
of
of evacuating scripture of all the weird
stuff all the stuff that
was problematic for people
um kind of cleaning up scripture making
it look uh
decent but uh but that's not uh
that's not necessarily a good thing
because a lot of the uh
a lot of the uh the
a lot of the the mysteries are in the
weird stuff you know a lot of the pearls
are hidden
in there so someone says to they
recommend the drawing uh
course by julia hayes yes definitely
julia
has a has a patreon project
which i think it's like a monthly you
pay like five dollars a month or ten
dollars a month for
however time you want to do it and she
she
she gives all these drawing classes
and she does uh like daily exercises and
she's really good like she really knows
how to draw she learned to draw
from george cordes uh
who is probably one of the best draft
people like one of the best drafts men
in terms of icons today
and so she she's quite good she can
really teach people the
the kind of logic the inner logic of
icons
i'm gonna destroy your ears with that
sorry all right
um
uh
someone says it delays the violence
vacuuming to the face it's not violent
you have to
understand it as purifying i'm purifying
the surface
all right
[Music]
um
all right do the nostril
uh
right
so in the face i tend to do the
the pupils of the irises towards the end
the inside of the eye
loose the end of the face
so i don't know if someone asked this
already but what what are your thoughts
on that nft that sold 69 million dollars
i have not see i haven't followed that
at all so i don't know
well i don't even know what is it of
what is the nft of it's is it an image
what is it it's a song
i mean it's like i guess people are just
wanting to be
to be like right just
right in there they want to be in the
new thing they want to be the new
fangirl they see it as the future
so
all right so now the eyes are
the trickiest thing
so someone asked if i'm the first person
to venerate all my icons
you know it's a it's a tricky thing the
whole venerating your own icons
you know i have an icon that i carved
towards the beginning of my
on my carving practice from
from the early days and i kept it
uh and i use it sometimes like i use it
for
for uh for during prayer like we'll put
it up
uh while we're doing morning prayers and
stuff but
it's always a little awkward because
it's hard to look at your own work and
not be looking at it
technically and so
and so it's a tricky thing for me to
venerate my
my own icons
[Music]
i'm not saying it is impossible but it
just i don't
so this is the only part where i'm going
to redraw
because the eyes are
so the wake will ask do you think the
newness of canada makes your convergent
orthodoxy more possible
in europe it feels like the weight of
history makes it difficult
um it's possible
maybe the spirit of like north america
you know the there's a reason why
um in north america is where a lot of
the
the
the first like translating into english
happen they're translating into other
languages but
there are other places where like for
example in russia there was a moment
where there were
there were a nice amount of converts
in uh in fran paris for example
so it just depends where you are
the thing is that if you're if you're in
a place where
the the ethnic group that brought
orthodoxy has only been there for a
short time
very short time then you're gonna you're
gonna have a problem
you're gonna have the problem of uh of a
kind of ethnicism and
you'll have the problem of not having
liturgies in in
in english in your language and them
also not understanding why you would
want to become orthodox in the first
place
whereas in america you know the russian
emigres
you know ended up having a kind of more
evangelical
spirit you could say and in the
the generations with which came after
the
the first waves of russian immigrant
emigrates after the revolution
there's enough time for them to kind of
assimilate the to french and english
culture to kind of develop
to want to translate and to develop a
version of orthodoxy which could be
understood by
by a westerner so
all right so we have the iris
i'm actually going to use a exacto knife
for this
you get into the little little details
my face in front of the camera
no that's too sharp
so
[Music]
i don't like to talk to talk while i'm
doing the the pupils because
that's for sure a place where i don't
want to mess up
so
so
also have these smaller tools that i use
for
uh doing detail stuff
i have a whole like i have also have a
whole set of tools that i use for like
actual miniatures
all right so then there's some fixing to
do
her eyelid is too low actually
you know when the eyelid is too low and
the character
the person looks sleepy
so you want to avoid that sleepy look
so mike says since you're backlogged
with orders what other iconographers
would you recommend to look at
uh depends what do you mean by carving
or do you mean
um
just icon painting
carving
there are a few
out there um
there's um one of my students ron
slockett you can look him up he's on
social media
he's been getting better like he's he's
been uh
he's been doing
pretty well um there's there's
there's someone his like who kind of
taught me some carving his name is
george belak i don't know if he still
carves though
um there's uh there's a
there's a greek iconographer who's
amazing doing ivory and bone carving
his name his name is michael lucas
l-o-u-k-a-s
written in greek though um and you can
order stuff from from him
from greece like he'll he'll make it for
you um
there's also someone oh man his name
escapes me right now he's gonna hate me
for not remembering his name uh
one of aiden hart's students is really
good
if you go on my facebook feed and you
scroll down you'll find i
posted a i posted
a an image of of his uh
his visit visit of the magi my guy
magi um visitation
not visitation but the the the visit of
the magi to the mother of god after
she gave birth and his carvings are
really really good
aiden heart is a really good carver but
i'm sure he's probably as busy as i am
he was carving before i was like long
before i was
um there's also
there are a few other people that kind
of caught me off guard
and i don't remember people's names and
and i feel bad because they'll think
it's because i
don't like them but it's not the case um
so michael boomer asked you having to
print somebody apprenticing with you
um actually no i i just have
my assistant it's hard to have someone
apprenticing with you with cogot and
everything especially now
like i couldn't have them stay here or
anything so it's just not practical
so my assistant has his own workshop and
uh
and i'll visit him or he'll come here
when we need to see each other and to
trade off carvings or to talk about
the next projects
the simpler world like i i'd be happy to
have
uh people
so scotland says hey jonathan i have the
four advantages from you from last
carving sales our family loves them it's
really cool to see your process in
action that's awesome
you got the four yeah that's that's
amazing i'm happy you have them
it's nice to know that they're all in
the same place too that's pretty cool
all right so you're starting to really i
mean the face is pretty much done
i'll all i need i need to do to make the
ears
and the ears i really do i just have a
very simple
shape i don't make the ears elaborate at
all
actually just to suggest
[Applause]
all right
so let's look at this
i need to make sure that all my uh
that all these these lines are gone
[Laughter]
so
suggest this fold here
just so it's not too boring
same here suggest these folds
you
[Music]
all right and so i also need to create
the band
because she has a band around her veil
so
so
[Applause]
someone says don't breathe in the dust
yeah that's my sin
when i get into little details i really
struggle because i blow on the dust to
make it go away
yeah that's definitely something that
i'm i'm not good at
especially when it takes just a little
bit of dust and uh it's kind of blow on
it it's horrible
it's like the worst thing ever it's it's
like
gypsum silica silica dust
so i'm just one of the important things
one of the things that makes a carving
look very uh subtle is
is like you don't have just lines you
have changes of level and so
so i carve the line to make the band uh
appear
i'm not just leaving it as a line i'm
actually i'm actually making sure that
the band is on top of the clothing
i got this guy in here
[Music]
um
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Applause]
[Music]
wow
all right so
just need to put in some subtle eyebrows
eyebrows are a big question because if
you look at ancient
ancient carving like even a lot of
ancient um
ivory carvings uh they don't have
eyebrows
and uh and so once once aiden
who's uh who i respect and admire like
he's an amazing
artist uh iconographer wrote me and said
you shouldn't you shouldn't carve
eyebrows you should you should just
leave it you know because ancient
ancient carvings have uh don't have
eyebrows
and uh and i thought about it and
i decided that i'm gonna continue to
carve eyebrows because
the reason i think that ancient carvings
didn't have eyebrows
is because they were um they were
painted
like even the carved the carved
the carved icons were were most often
painted in color and so then they would
have put the eyebrows
in color but because i don't because
mine aren't
then
i've decided to put eyebrows
so
did someone said didn't know the mona
lisa was an icon
because she doesn't have eyebrows that's
funny
uh
so
so one of the things is that when i cut
with a knife let's say i need to go back
because it's
it gets kind of um
it's kind of crunchy on the edges that i
carved for the first time i don't know
what other word to use
all right i'll use the band here
so someone asked if i prayed before
carving uh
yes um i pray i
have morning prayers i don't necessarily
have like i so some iconographers they
have something it's a late it's a late
thing which but it's fine there's
something called the iconographer's
prayer and so you can find it online if
you're interested
and then some people you know when they
actually go into the workshop then
they'll
they'll pray that particular prayer
[Laughter]
all right and so now last step actually
pretty much is going to be the star
[Music]
[Music]
so the story is it
um and so eurodivi
asked are there any particular
iconographers saints you have an
affinity towards
i mean i think for sure said andre i
mean it's hard not to he's so
like his icons are so amazing and so
mystical so for sure said andre rublev
um i mean saint theodore the study is
important just because he was really
i mean if he's an iconographer he's not
really an iconographer he's more like a
defender of icons
um
[Music]
i learned i i i didn't i guess i didn't
know but it
it i've heard that saint pauicios of the
holy mountain who died
in the 90s was it was carving icons
and so it's pretty awesome i'd love to
see
his icons
all right so
this is going to be carved almost like a
chip carving i don't know if you guys
know what chip carving is but
if i carve one side on like this
then i'm going to carve the other side
the camera was about to fall there sorry
guys
sorry for the shakiness here
so michael walmart says seeing the
theotokos gradually appear
has been quite moving for me thank you
for doing this live today
well you know it's my pleasure i'm
really happy to be able to do this
i'm always kind of looking for ways to
to show that i really appreciate the
opportunity
all you guys are giving me to talk about
symbolism
to to have a of a kind of public voice
and uh it's all because of of you guys
and i really appreciate it
so we'll see if people like this then uh
i'll be happy to do it again
if people appreciate this
not too much because
get the sense that streaming like people
who stream every day like god bless them
and everything but
i always feel like it it's probably
dangerous to stream every day just
because you're definitely gonna end up
saying something
stupid that you'll regret if you just
leave the camera on and babylon for
hours and hours
you know it's like asking for trouble
[Music]
me
nice all right so last little thing is
going to be the
stripes on her veil she has these uh
these bands on her inner veil
someone says i hope he doesn't delete i
will not i won't delete it i'll leave up
this i'll leave this video up
it would be part of our part of the 100
000
celebration
someone says orthodox bob ross
man
again all of a sudden i was gonna like
start imitating him
which had been highly inappropriate
all right and so it's basically there
and then what i'm gonna do is i'm gonna
i'm definitely gonna go back and uh
fiddle and uh fix a few things
also it's always a good idea to
usually to leave some time because you
you end up not seeing certain things if
you
spend too much time on one carving at
least that's my experience
so
[Music]
well that's pretty much it the last
thing that i would
i could do is i would put the
inscription and then
i would sand
i would sand a few parts like the parts
that are
that are messy for example if you look
at the
the halo it still has some marks in
there so that's kind of easy to take off
with some sandpaper
and these pencil marks and stuff little
little things like that
but it's pretty much pretty much done
and so i think i'm going to uh i'm gonna
stop the stream now
um so yeah thanks guys for tuning in
it was uh it was a lot of fun i liked it
and so maybe i'll do it again at some
point
think about it and uh and so thanks
again like i said thanks for the
attention thanks for the support
everybody
i really appreciate it and so uh and so
uh
see you guys very soon bye-bye
so i don't know how to stop this there
you go